asalam
alikum if the soul is breathed into the
fetus after 4 months then why is it that
abortion before 4 months is considered
as killing this as the question that if
the soul is Beed into the fet at 4
months then why is killing before 4
months counted as Haram sister once you
realize that taking life is
prohibited for example we know that
there are many of the living creatures
don't have soul
the Hadith the soul is not there of many
living creatures but if you kill that
living creature that doesn't mean it's
allowed you can't even kill a sparrow
for without any reason beloved Prophet
wasallam said killing any living
creature is Haram whether it had Soul or
not if killing a creature with a soul
carries a bigger sin that's a different
question altogether so we have to
realize that killing living creature per
is Haram sister in Islam so you can't
say that just because animal has got no
so I can kill an animal if you have a
reason which is permitted in Islam fine
so that's the reason even in Islam once
it has formed a zygote the sperm and the
OM have joined to form a zygote then
destroying that life becomes Haram in
Islam hope that the question sister yes
brother